alongside immigration Donald Trump's
promise to fix the US economy and
especially to do it in a way that helps
working Americans not just the rich was
the reason he was elected look at the
contrast between Wall Street now and the
real economy in the last few months the
stock market tanked over fears that the
economy was heading in the wrong
direction but in the real world the
American consumer the engine of our
economy powered ahead holiday sales hit
their highest mark in six years
Wall Street hates the president's
policies on trade because they make life
harder for rich corporate executives
with a globalist outlet as outlook but
in the real world they're helping
exactly the people in this country that
Donald Trump promised hell the
unemployment gap between skilled and
unskilled workers is shrinking wages are
rising and the lowest overall
unemployment in half a century is
forcing companies to hire workers they
may have overlooked in the past that's
what I call positive populism so here we
are back with work with Tesla and Henry
and Lisa Tesla I just wanna start with
you on this what's the chances that some
that the blue-collar workers the kind of
the Democrats who kind of went to Donald
Trump because they wanted this kind of
policy seems like they've drifted away a
bit we saw that a little bit in 2018 do
you think this success will bring them
back to the president's camp in the
years ahead well you know that was such
a great point that you brought us Steve
I'm so appreciative for because that's
where the Democrat Party really fails
they fail to talk about business owners
they seem to make even Bernie Sanders
data you know Wall Street Wall Shivratri
that's a big difference between Wall
Street and me being a small business
owner huge difference between who I was
able to employ how it made a positive
influence in my community and the
Democrats have unfortunately went so far
left that everything is about the evil
evil Wall Street where they've forgotten
about of the average working person that
is actually benefiting from this economy
and for you to put that contrast to show
that even though the stock market is
tanked the economy is still done well
that's really important I think
Democrats are going in the wrong
direction which will eventually move
more people over to trump are closer to
Trump instead of actually talking about
business so it's almost like they're
paralyzed to talk about it because
everything is on social issues social
issues social issues I was the racial
justice director for Bernie Sanders I
understand the importance of social
issues but I also understand the
importance of having a
engine as well it doesn't create solve
our social problems but it sure makes it
a hell of a lot easier and that's where
Democrats yeah failing where you'll see
the big divide between your moderates
your Nancy Pelosi's your people who are
in the middle the other says you're very
far ring left all of a sudden
progressives who became progressive six
months ago that'll be running for
president 2020 this Wall Street I mean
all that you know we just look at that
you think Oh Mike everything's falling
apart but all the time you've just had
good news for the American worker yeah
it's been great news for the American
worker it's gonna get better is that
we've got that big increase in
manufacturing jobs you talked about and
the renegotiated NAFTA doesn't even take
effect for a couple years that's gonna
push more auto manufacturing in this
country the deal that's gonna get cut
with China this year and there's gonna
be a deal who's gonna push more
manufacturing back to the United States
it's just gonna get better and once we
cut down on the number of illegal
immigrants who are taking American jobs
over five million people not legally
here in the country who are working in
America that's going to create more
demand for the marginals unskilled
worker push wages up even more and it
would be like wonderful news for
President Trump going to 2020 very
optimistic but sometimes I think that
the you know that the the the Wall
Street negativity could sort of infect
the real economy potentially but also I
think the coverage of the White House I
think that streets right well the sense
of you know if the media focuses on
volatility then you know I think that's
gonna translate in the market personally
but the reason why I think what the
blue-collar workers with 20 18
Republicans that do quite as well is
because President Trump wasn't on the
ballot and presidents Trump's a path
through the victory through the White
House was always through the Rust Belt
and again in 2020 it's gonna be through
the Rust Belt and I think why President
Trump was so refreshing to a lot of
these blue-collar workers is one you had
President Obama that pursued a policy of
identity politics and forgot about all
these the rest of America especially
middle America and President Trump spoke
to those people and you also had look at
an issue like coal you'd present Obama
literally waging a war on coal you would
someone like Hillary Clinton saying that
she wanted to put co-workers and you
know co-workers out of business and then
here you have a president President
Trump coming in and or a candidate the
Trump coming in and saying I care about
you I know you're hurting and I want
jobs to come back to your communities so
imagine how refreshing that justice
to those individuals and clearly he's
following through and that's the key
again to the rest before him for 2020
yeah
great I agree and of course it will
depend very much who the Democrats
picked as either they can they can
challenge that in any way thank you all
very much